Thank You New Hampshire shortly after  the polls close Secretary Clinton called  and was very gracious in her  congratulations I thank her for her call  and I congratulate her and her  supporters for the vigorous campaign  they ran over and let me take this  opportunity to thank the many many  thousands of volunteers here in the  Granite State who work so tirelessly  together we have sent the message that  will echo from Wall Street to Washington  from Maine to California  and that is that the government of our  great country belongs to all of the  people and not just a handful of wealthy  campaign contributors and their super  PACs